In this lesson we covered some pretty advanced topics,
and I hope you enjoyed them or were able
to follow along. But let's actually see if we
can summarize these ideas into four main points. Point one,
pharmacogenetics is the study of how our genes influence
our reactions to particular drugs. Point two, pharmadynamics concerns
itself with, what a drug does to your body,
specifically how it binds to a particular protein and creates
a particular effect. Point three, pharmacokinetics is about what your
body does to a drug, in other words, how your body metabolizes or clears
the drug from its system. And point four, genetic variability in the
pharmacodynamic and pharmacokinetic pathways influences the
toxicity and efficacy of a drug.